Hey,
I've been gone for a while.
Part of the reason is I just got back
from my honeymoon,
which was awesome,
and also for the past few weeks I've
been working partly on a new coffee
break and partly on a brand new series
called coffee with,
which is an interview show where I
explore the lives of creators,
the first one being well or a fellow
video sas.
If you like me,
if you like what I do,
you feel like people like me and you're
going to love this show,
so please go check it out.
Support the channel.
Now,
just so you know,
it's a new channel,
so if you're subscribed to me,
you're not going to be subscribed to the
new channel.
Please also subscribe to that.
If you like content,
you want to see more of it.
Thank you so much and,
uh,
leave some feedback.
Let me know what you think.
It's the first episodes.
Of course there are some problems,
but I think it's the start of something
that could be really cool and I think
you guys might really like it.
So,
uh,
here's a trailer.
The link is down below.
Okay.
Welcome to New York.
So I tried shooting this intro live
several times,
but each time I miserably failed.
So let me start again.
This is an interview show called coffee
with where I have interesting
conversations over coffee with youtube
or anyone that's interesting.
This is the first episode where but
amazing will scooter,
but before we get to who he is and start
the show,
I want to tell you why I created coffee
with,
now that I finished the interview and
have had time to collect my thoughts.
If you don't know me,
I run coffee,
break a video as a channel where I break
down big ideas,
but besides being a creator myself,
I'm also a really big fan of other
youtubers that break down big ideas.
I love when someone can teach complex
ideas and are on the cutting edge of
using media to do so and I want to talk
with some of these people,
discuss their ideas,
inspirations and origins.
Usually these people are behind a
curtain and professionalism and their
videos,
but if you strip that away and just talk
with them,
you find that there unexpectedly witty
or funny or kind,
and I want to show that over a cup of
coffee.
This will be available as a podcast,
as a video interview on Youtube and
highlight should also be going up soon.
For our first guest.
We have will scooter.
He makes videos on culture,
irony,
postmodernism philosophy,
that brain and even Mr Rogers.
In this interview we talk about what it
means to be a video sas.
We Talk Philosophy,
the age of distraction.
We live in will's gratitude notes.
He writes every morning and more.
It's a little slow going at first,
but I think we hit our stride toward the
middle and some really cool stuff comes
out of the conversation.
Grab a cup of coffee,
grab a cozy couch.
Here's me fund in New York City and
here's what we talked about.